I've seen who kind of referred to as the
fixer or Miss fix-it are you are you am
i I like to fix things what can I say I
do like to fix things
sandy Peterson came to Johnson & Johnson
with a reputation for fixing things at
other companies and at J&J there was
plenty to fix including massive global
recalls between 2009 and 2012 there was
also a government takeover of three
tylenol plants and billions of dollars
in payments to resolve lawsuits
most of this happened before Peterson
came on board and 2012
coming in how much did you know and what
did you think initially about whether or
not they could tackle all of the recalls
the manufacturing problems and so on
the lawsuits it was fixable it would
take time but it was very fixable part
of what needed to be fixed
dealing with a company that included
some 250 businesses that some say was
too big to manage we have become a much
larger more complicated company with
many many more businesses which you know
it was a wonderful thing but we really
needed to say how do we actually manage
this much larger enterprise in a
different way going forward the new way
Ford began in 2010 when J&J began
streamlining operations and putting in
uniform quality control standards around
the globe we basically took a pause and
said we're gonna go to every single plan
and make sure that we understand what we
need to do to have consistent
appropriate standards in all of these
plants so we didn't have an integrated
system now we do so it was it like you
knocked down a ton of factories or had
to buy a lot of new technology to kind
of get up to snuff if you well that's
not what it was all right what does he
know it was not about that at all J&J
did though got its Fort Washington
Pennsylvania factory spending 100
million dollars to rebuild it from the
ground up expected to open early next
year the plant will remain under
government monitoring for five years so
if someone sees a change a recall as a
consumer as an investor how should they
read that they should read it as we did
the right thing the thing they should
say is did they take quick action
I wouldn't interpret a recall
necessarily as a bad thing because of
the systems that we have in place the
safety metrics that we have in place the
quality metrics 75% of the consumer
products that were recalled are back on
the shelf with the rest coming by 2016
it takes a few years to turn a turn a
business in the right direction but
we've actually got better momentum than
I thought we would have